you know him as the pumpkin king and you
definitely don't know him as Sandy Claws
but what do only adults notice about
Jack Skellington
Jack Skellington is known as the Pumpkin
King but what does that title actually
mean Jack certainly isn't a monarch and
Halloween Town already has a leader it's
two-faced mayor sure Jack helps organize
the spooking and scaring that takes
place on Halloween and gives some great
speeches along the way but it's tough to
say what exactly he does for an actual
job so he's a leader who holds no real
political power he supposedly has a
knack for motivating people and he's a
consultant to the powers that be yet
it's hard to put your finger on what
exactly he does for a real job it seems
like Jack Skellington is basically
halloweentown's version of the British
royal family Jack truly is royalty as
his title implies and his status is
complete with the abject boredom that
you'd expect from someone who exists to
be a figurehead no wonder he's jealous
of the hard-working much credited Santa
Claus at least Santa actually gets to do
something
while Tim Burton wrote his delightfully
creepy poem The Nightmare Before
Christmas all the way back in 1982 the
first Hollywood feature film to truly
nail the director's trademark spooky
aesthetic wouldn't come until 1988 with
Beetlejuice it's showtime
many of the details in Beetlejuice are
similar to elements of The Nightmare
Before Christmas when Gina Davis and
Alec Baldwin are brought back in the
Seance scene for example their faces
have the same distinct wrinkly lines
seen on the faces of the Dead in
Halloweentown Beetlejuice uses games as
a way to torture the people similar to
Oogie Boogie's antagonism toward Jack
Skellington and Santa Claus and the
statues coming to life in Beetlejuice
are echoed by the kids walking bathtub
in Nightmare there's even a ghostly hat
decoration in Beetlejuice that looks
eerily similar to Jack Skellington when
Beetlejuice finally gets to have his fun
and haunt the humans he appears wearing
a distinctive hat at the top is a man
with a hollow-eyed skull in a familiar
shape adorned by a bat that looks a lot
like Jack's bow tie whether this hat
topper is based on idea for Jack
Skellington or the other way around the
resemblance is unmistakable
Jack's black and white suit looks like
it's glued on and getting it on and off
must be a straight up nightmare moreover
when Jack's Santa suit is destroyed when
his sled is blown up by the military
later in the movie It's revealed that he
was wearing his pinstripe suit under the
Santa suit the whole time therefore it
would seem Jack never takes his suit off
and we don't know if he actually can if
he can't that would make sense for more
than just aesthetic reasons getting back
to the fact that Jack is a skeleton and
skeletons are held together by soft
tissue that eventually rots away you
could argue that he would fall apart
without a suit obviously there's already
a lot of suspension of disbelief that
needs to occur in order to accept most
of what we see in Halloweentown yet it
would make sense that Jack's suit also
serves the purpose of keeping his bones
together just like skin keeps our
insides from falling out in a sense Jack
Skellington has black and white
pinstriped skin like some sort of
bipedal zebra
why does Jack task lock shock and barrel
with kidnapping the holiday icon he
mistakenly refers to as Sandy Claus even
more alarmingly why does he assume that
the kids also refer to as boogies boys
wouldn't go right to Oogie Boogie and
Spill the Beans seriously for a
character who's so smart that the mayor
needs his guidance on the yearly
Halloween plans you've got to wonder why
would Jack ever trust these impish
trick-or-treaters for one thing they're
not the sharpest tools in the shed since
they accidentally kidnapped the Easter
Bunny instead of Santa secondly
everybody in Halloweentown loves Jack
and holds him in the highest esteem
surely he could have found an eager and
loyal helper anywhere else so why would
he instead pick three kids who at best
treat him with amused disdain it's not
like Jack doesn't know about their
association with Oogie Boogie and one
more thing
that no account Oogie Boogie out of this
so he knows where their true loyalties
lie but decides to count on them anyway
it seems that jack isn't as clever as
the residence of Halloweentown think
as he sings The Number Jack's Lament
Jack removes his head holding it out
like Hamlet holds the exhumed Jester
York skull while reciting his famous
alasporic speech the fact that Jack is a
skeleton and can therefore bend the
rules of his Anatomy allows him to
embody both Yorick and hamlet in the
recreation of this Shakespearean scene
while this self-decapitation lasts just
for a moment during Jack's sweeping song
about identity and futility it speaks
very strongly to who Jack really is one
part of him is Hamlet full of on WE and
self-doubt wondering at the purpose of
his existence but another part of him is
the jester Yorick the silly fool who can
make you laugh and cry who can tumble
and fall and get back up with a big
smile in this one moment Jack shows just
how complicated he truly is
in animation nearly every detail on
screen is drawn on purpose and this goes
especially for a movie produced by a man
known for crafting a very specific
detailed aesthetic style in The
Nightmare Before Christmas Jack
Skellington's hands show the joints
between his knuckles which makes sense
as this emphatic leader is big on hand
gestures and physical articulation but
if he needs joints to move his fingers
how does he move his neck that looks
like one single fused bone rather than a
stack of vertebrae sure it has wrinkles
but there don't appear to be any joints
based simply on how skeletons work
Jack's neck couldn't bend Twist and Turn
without vertebrae after all bones don't
move and bend themselves but instead
achieve Mobility through the combined
efforts of their muscles and Joints how
does the ever introspective Jack Bend
his neck in contemplation and wonderment
then such deep questions hard-hitting
and poignant may never be answered
Disney had some serious apprehensions
about producing The Nightmare Before
Christmas as a children's movie their
concerns about the horror elements LED
Disney to release the film under the
company's grown-up subsidiary Touchstone
pictures instead of the main Disney
label
how horrible our Christmas will be no
how Jolly the entertainment giant also
requested a few changes for example
Disney execs demanded that Jack
Skellington Should Have Eyes in his
sockets they say the eyes are the
windows to the soul a fountain of
emotion that allows people to relate to
each other so perhaps Disney was worried
that Jack would seem lacking in
personality without them or maybe the
studio was worried that Jack Skellington
would look too sinister for younger
audiences luckily producer Creator Tim
Burton and director Henry Selleck stood
their ground on the point that Jack is
in fact a skeleton and skeletons don't
have eyes it's a good thing they stood
strong too because Jack now a beloved
character doesn't seem to have suffered
any kind of hit for having empty eye
sockets in fact his face is so
expressive that kids may not even notice
that he has no eyes even if Disney
definitely did
of course people emote with more than
just their eyes for example a fair bit
of emotion comes across in the eyebrows
and the mouth without eyes Jack has to
depend even more on these kinds of
facial reactions the only problem with
this of course is that skulls can't
actually move muscles and skin create
the appearance of brows going up or down
as well as contorting the lips into a
smile or a Grimace the human skull
doesn't move in real life since bone is
solid certainly there has to be some
artistic license at play to give a
skeleton Without Eyes some semblance of
emotion and to that end the animators
afford Jack's skeleton face the same
flexibility he would have if it were
covered in skin it's almost as if Jack
Skellington's skull is made of clay
there are some weird things going on
with Jack Skellington anatomically
speaking one aspect of his body that
draws a critical eye is that his mouth
appears to be stitched together except
when it's not the lines running up and
down Jack's face could be seen simply as
stylized wrinkly lips at first like the
remnants of Flesh in a state of decay
but if you look toward the back of
Jack's skull his mouth looks like it's
just sewn together when you think about
it this makes sense there are no muscles
to hold to the bottom and the top of his
jaw in place when closed his mouth looks
like it's strung together when open it's
as if the threads have magically split
except towards the back where they hold
the hinges of the jaw together so you
can probably add another unique feature
to Jack's Anatomy apparently string can
be sewn through his bone to take the
place of muscles and tendons Jack
Skellington is truly a medical Marvel
Jack Skellington is a collection of
bones without connective or protective
tissue held together in large part by a
suit possibly with stitches securing his
Jaws you wouldn't think that makes for a
particularly durable body yet Jack gets
hammered by cannon fire and escapes with
little more than a burned Santa suit at
another point he leaps around Oogie's
projectiles and traps like a bona fide
gymnast and even if Jack had been hit he
probably would have come out feeling
fine take the movie's final act for
example the Pumpkin King is blasted out
of the sky by the military and springs
back up almost immediately even
retaining enough strength and power to
return home and save Santa Claus and
Sally perhaps there's some truth to the
idea that you can't die twice
foreign